There's a super interesting new piece in the
nation written by Sasha Abramski, which says
that there are now even some Republicans worried
that indeed Donald Trump is trying to figure
out how to retain control regardless of the
outcome of the November election, which is
now under eight weeks away.
It's eight weeks minus one day.
And they're actually using the word coup to
describe the possibility of what Donald Trump
may do if indeed he loses to Joe Biden on
November 3rd.
And this article by Sasha Abramski in The
Nation, which we're linking to and I encourage
you to read quotes Charles Freed.
Charles Freed is a Harvard Law School professor,
still a Republican, as far as far as I know,
right now.
And Charles Freed is increasingly worried
about Donald Trump's electoral strategy of
seemingly encouraging chaos and violence and
is even talking about how this strategy is
ripe for Donald Trump to actually send in
provocateurs into largely left leaning protests
in order to make them seem more violent, in
order to try to justify his reelection or
as a sort of double goal to claim that things
are so crazy we can't really be sure the election
was done correctly.
If he doesn't win and this is a classic authoritarian
provocateur strategy, we've seen this the
world over.
We've seen it for decades and decades.
That's Charles Freed.
Michael Steele, the former chair of the Republican
National Committee.
We've talked about him on the program, relatively
well-known individual.
He is also concerned about the same possibility
in November.
And the difference would be Michael Steele
doesn't so much think that what's going on
is primarily authoritarianism.
But Michael Steele believes that it's really
political opportunism and Trump being determined
to retain control from a politically advantageous
perspective rather than simply sheer authoritarianism.
But the main takeaway and the most important
point here is that both Charles Freed and
Michael Steele believe that Donald Trump is
willing to do whatever he needs to do to remain
in the White House.
And Trump has been signaling this by attacking
vote by mail.
He's been saying he knows the election will
be rigged.
It'll be the worst, the most rigged, most
fraudulent election in history.
He's said this probably dozens, if not hundreds
of times at this point, and has been setting
up a situation where he lays the groundwork
not to accept the results of the election.
And then who knows what happens now.
What we're seeing is that there are actually
Republicans getting together with progressive
organizations to develop a specific plan for
responding to Trump, rejecting the results
of the election.
If he were to lose and they put together a
report and unfortunately, they are not confident
that our institutions will do their jobs.
They are saying it could take huge numbers
of Americans taking to the streets to make
their will be reflected in Donald Trump leaving
if indeed Donald Trump loses the election
and claims that it was rigged.
And these groups, which again, they now include
Republicans, these are not the left movement's
uniquely Republicans are also concerned.
They're also worried that Donald Trump will
do something I've been predicting for a long
time, which is that if Donald Trump is ahead
in certain states on election night, this
is the Red Mirage scenario.
Trump will deploy lawyers to file lawsuits
in various states to try to stop the counting
of absentee ballots, which, if fully counted,
could turn a small Trump margin on election
night into a small Biden margin and hand a
hand.
Joe Biden, the presidency, the The Indivisibility
Project, Stand Up America are two of these
groups.
They're bringing together a whole bunch of
different organizations to try to have a really
specific plan to prevent the electoral process
from being undermined and subverted and disenfranchisement
from running wild.
Now, I still maintain that Donald Trump will
not succeed at maintaining power if he loses.
I believe that he he will go if he loses.
But there is the very real possibility that
he will try and that he could create absolute
and total chaos for some time, including possibly
violence on the streets.
Ultimately, the way that this becomes dangerous
in a physical violence sense is if it's close
and Trump wins on election night, but starts
to say they're trying to take it from me,
I need you out there or loses by a small margin
on election night and says it was rigged.
I think those two scenarios are the ones that
will most likely weaponize, and that's literally
what it would be, his supporters with guns
to go out on the street.
Now, there's another side to this.
They are talk.
Thing about the word coup, as if a coup would
be necessary.
The unfortunate reality is that you don't
need a coup to undermine democracy and the
will of the people because the Electoral College
has helped Republicans do that in multiple
elections over the last several decades.
You can combine the disenfranchizing nature
of the Electoral College with the suppression
of the vote and everything else that we're
seeing where you wouldn't even really need
a coup.
In other words, Trump may be able to pull
this off simply with doing enough voter suppression,
enough voter purges, et cetera, that the Electoral
College hands him a victory even when he law
loses the popular vote and really should have
lost the electoral vote as well.
The point is, we have to be ready for this.
And it is not merely the stuff of imagination,
theory and fantasy at this point.
We've seen the groundwork laid in real time
proclaiming that this election, which could
remove Donald Trump, will be the most rigged
and fraudulent one in history.
And my biggest concern is what is the Joe
Biden campaign doing about it to be ready?
What are Democrats doing about this?
To be ready?
Because if they aren't ready, that would be
a disaster they need.
I was going to say just as many lawyers, they
probably need twice as many lawyers as Trump
has ready to try to stop counting absentee
ballots.
They need twice as many lawyers to ensure
that absentee ballots are counted.
And it actually could come down to that.
It could get very ugly very quickly.
I'm not confident that the Biden campaign
and the Democratic Party are ready.
Why?
Because they've been not ready so many other
times in history.
But they absolutely need a plan.
They need the lawyers ready to go.
And we're going to be very closely following
whether they do have that system
in place.